foreign
[Music]
nolas
this is my presentation how one time I
made an entire e-commerce platform on
shiny they said it couldn't be done but
I did it what is that platform that
platform is ggirl which is to make your
GG plots in real life some people may
pronounce it g girl but it is officially
GT IRL you can install it via remotes
install github.nos djirl and what it
does it lets you take a GG plot you've
made that's beautiful that you wish
existed in the Physical Realm you can
then pay a modest fee and very soon you
will get an actual postcard delivered to
a friend or family member
but it's all cool to talk about it let's
actually see how it works instead so I'm
going to immediately switch out a
PowerPoint and switch to a live demo so
I'm running this in Saturn Cloud I'm
just going to open up our studio and so
let's say you have a plot you like like
let's say you have this
souvenir commemorative or RC
oh oh no
I think we're also yeah we're missing it
is it not showing up right here can I do
that yeah cool good that would have been
tragic because of the best part
uh here we go let's see if I can do this
over here yes okay great let's say you
have this souvenir commemorative ggrl
plot oh God I'm gonna have to do it like
this oh no I I see it we're good okay
so you have the souvenir commemorative
gtrl plot you can then go and you can
use this GG postcard function which
takes a plot the contact email for the
order confirmation the message you want
to put on the back of the postcard like
this is a great conference thanks for
putting on and the address of a friend
or family member in this case I'm going
to send it to our friends at rstudio I
mean pause it
um in Boston Massachusetts so in several
weeks their headquarters is going to be
confused why they got a postcard but
here we are so I'm gonna hit that and
what's gonna happen is it's gonna think
for a second and then it's gonna launch
an entirely separate shiny server this
is a shiny server running somewhere else
it is not running on my computer it is
running actually on Saturn cloud
so in the front you can see the preview
of the postcard it shows you the message
it shows you the address it has one
button and that's pay and submit when
you hit pay and submit
oh God this is so hard there we go okay
great when you hit pay and submit it
thinks for a second and sends you to
stripe in stripe it asks you for money
so I'm going to go ahead and put in my
credit card information just kidding
cyber stalkers
um
so you do that and then if you did
somehow put in your credit card
information in front of a bunch of
people you would then very soon get an
email confirming that you made the order
in one to two weeks you will get a
physical postcard of your GG plot that's
right the first presentation you've seen
with physical props
your message is on the back it's not the
ggr hex sticker oh I think I just doxed
myself in my address
um
cool okay so now we're back to
PowerPoint and let's see if I can pop
this back up
ah
uh let me you got it okay great cool
um cool so that was the demo as you saw
it went from R to a shiny app to stripe
and then somehow a postcard appeared but
how does it work how does it work
um how does it work there we go how does
it work okay so there's a our package
called GT IRL that's what you install on
your computer and talks to shiny server
and then there's a shiny server called
ggirl server which does all the work of
showing the user preview passing the
information to stripe fulfilling the
postcard via an API so there's a service
somewhere I call to make the postcard go
and then sends a confirmation email now
if you think about it ggir server should
be multiple shiny apps and plumber apis
there's no reason why the Fulfillment
why the uploading the information should
be done via shiny it's better probably
better to do that as an API be a plumber
but for ease of Maintenance I'm like I
really just want one shiny app to do all
of this and by ease of Maintenance I
mean I'm super lazy and I don't want to
have to keep a bunch of microservices
running I just want one but to make this
work leaves a lot of engineering
questions which I'm gonna enumerate now
one is how do you pass the plot from R
to shiny if you think about it shiny
there's a lot of times where shiny has
data loaded into it right you can read
data from a database in shiny you can
press the upload button on shiny but if
you think about it there's not really an
obvious way that if a shiny server is
running how can you programmatically
send data to it so I don't want it to
read data on load I want to just pass
the data to a server that's running it
may not even have a web page open I just
want it to listen for data
so the way you would do that in like web
development land is you do to http post
request so an HTTP post request is only
an API or a website receives data so
when you hit submit on like a website
your browser is doing a post request to
the server
um that should be done with a post
request shiny does not have the ability
to a documented ability to listen for
post requests normally only plumber does
that
it should have this and that's my call
out to our studio I mean pause it um I
think that would be a really great
feature the good news is there's
actually a number of undocumented ways
to do this and so again what I'm trying
to do is I'm trying to post the image to
shiny so here's the plot I've made and
then I want shiny to come back to me
with okay here's the ID of that image of
like cool I got the image I'm going to
call it FC whatever and then the package
is going to be like okay cool I'm then
going to take the user to the browser
website to actually do the preview
so this is a back and forth of the post
request so there are a number of
undocumented ways to do this the way I
like the most is you use the brochure
package by Colin Faye this is an
experimental package that lets you can
this is an experimental package that
lets you connect multiple shiny apps
together so if you have like three
different shiny apps and you're like man
I really wish all of them were running
at once you can bundle them all up into
one shiny app using brochure you can
also listen to requests besides get so
if you want to have your shiny app
listen for data not just show web pages
brochure will let you do that too so
this actually solves two of my problems
one it lets me listen for post data and
two I can actually have a bunch of
concurrent shiny apps one for the order
upload one for the Fulfillment one for
the preview
um it does it's so new it doesn't even
have a hex sticker It also says all over
it experimental do not use in production
but here I am using in production and
it's working great thanks Colin
um if you want to see examples of the
other ways that are actually built into
shiny to do Post requests I have a link
at the bottom and you can check it out
cool so how do you show the image
preview so once we have the data
uploaded to shiny how do we show the
image well this is actually just a shiny
app with one button what I do is I have
the URL you go to have the token which
is the ID of the particular postcard you
uploaded I have that in the URL and then
the shiny servers show the shiny app
shows a different postcard depending on
what your token is
now I put a lot of work into the
bootstrap and the CSS to make it all
look pretty and to get the margins on
the postcard right and all that I have a
whole separate talk about making your
shiny apps look pretty that I gave at
shinyconf 2022
um so if you want like 45 minutes of
hearing about how to make your shiny abs
look pretty I suggest you check out that
talk it's it was a lot of fun
So Okay cool so we have a shiny app it
shows you the preview of the thing it
got the data from a post request from R
but how do we then pass the user from
shiny to Stripe Right how do I make that
pay and submit button send someone to
stripe I thought this would be the
hardest part of the app but it actually
was surprisingly easy to make this
um they're really just two steps in the
payment flow first is you need shiny to
send stripe what is actually in the
shopping cart of the user which is
called the stripe session you do this
via a post request by the way it turns
out ggirl is like 95 just post requests
bouncing around and this is another one
it's not the last
um you then also once you've posted the
cart you then have to have the user go
to the shiny page or the stripe page so
stripe has an a JavaScript API to get
users to the appropriate stripe checkout
page I refuse to learn JavaScript I will
never do this the good
yeah I've I'm not alone here great
um
the good news is is that shiny makes it
very easy I found out to use other
people's JavaScript apis so what you do
is you use you add tags dollar sign
script to the top of your shiny app to
load in the JavaScript API and then use
shiny dot custom message Handler so that
when the action button is pressed for
pay and submit it will call that special
uh JavaScript so it's really just two
steps and again if you want to see the
particular code you can go to that ggrl
examples repo and you can see an example
there
so this gets the user from shiny to
stripe where they presumably pay money
because they are excited about a
postcard
um how do you then fulfill the order so
how do you have shiny then listen for
Stripes striping like okay cool they
paid you money now we're gonna go ahead
and make the order
so we do this with a post request
um so we're gonna have stripes send a
post request telling shiny to order the
postcards so if your server is listening
for someone else's post request that is
called a web hook it's just a different
name for another post request it's just
kind of going in the other direction so
we're going to use a web hook saying hey
order XYZ or fce six whatever the order
number is has been paid for and to make
sure that like people just don't know
what that URL is and spam it to get a
million postcards we are going to add
keys to ensure that the message actually
came from stripe itself
um so stripe will then um so shiny will
receive the request and be like okay
cool the order is placed and then shiny
will call the the stuff to send the
postcard and send the email so and uh
this feels like it should be
straightforward right I've already done
two or three post requests as part of
this talk this is just another post
request
but here's the issue is that stripe
needs to know that the message was
received really quickly so if stripe
says the order was confirmed and stripe
doesn't hear right away that the order
actually like your app go like cool we
got the order should be like oh my God
they didn't hear it I gotta send it
again and here's the thing you might
know about shiny is shiny takes a while
when it's running stuff so if you're not
ah you guys are putting it together yes
this took me a while took too long to
put together that if you're not careful
stripe will ask for the order to be
submitted over and over and China would
be like cool got it cool got it cool got
it and the next thing you know you have
20 20 postcards sent to your house
um so the trick to solve this is you are
going to use caller package and caller's
a really cool package to run our
processes in the background so when you
get the order from stripe you're gonna
use caller to send like actually send
the postcard send the email that's all
going to happen in the background so
that shiny can immediately respond to
stripe being like yeah cool we got it
and not be bogged down by the time it
takes to send the postcard uh and to
submit the postcard order and send the
email
um I love using caller so much from
learning this that I actually made a
whole talk about using R in parallel um
which is a separate thing if you want to
learn about that I have a separate talk
for this
um and if you actually want to just see
the code that does this again ggrl
examples has that
so to actually fulfill the order I
needed to use caller to run R in the
background
and then to order the postcards it turns
out there are like tons of companies out
there that will make apis that if you
hit that API with a post request with a
message the address and the front of the
postcard they will ship it to that
location this makes sense because you
get lots of postcards in the mail for
advertisements so lots of companies use
these Services
um two problems here one it takes a
while to ship postcards right it takes
like two weeks to ship postcards so it
takes a while before you actually get
how the postcard back and two companies
that are sending millions of postcards
to every person in the country don't
care really how good the postcards look
as long as they're cheap so it took
forever for me to find a service that
was actually good and so it took two
weeks and I didn't like it in two weeks
and I didn't like it and in fact if you
see over there if you see in this image
on the presentation it looks kind of
blurry it looks like kind of like jpeg
artifacts like this is like a Facebook
meme that got sent to you too many times
that was not this picture I uploaded
that's what it actually looked like on
the postcard and that is beneath the
Dignity of ggplot2 plots
um so I had to spend a while by far this
is the longest part because I had to
spend a while until I find a printing
service that was actually good
to send the confirmation emails uh this
is actually pretty easy there's a
package blastula which can send those
emails so all I had to do to put the
preview in the email is I wanted to
resize it because those images had to be
very large for the printer and I wanted
to resize them so they weren't like five
Megs in your inbox so I used the package
image magic to resize them and get the
right margins and everything but
sometimes there would be an error in the
Fulfillment so not only did I have to
send an email to the users but if
anything ever goes wrong I want to make
sure I caught it so I'd have to send an
email to me and once in a while the
email system would have an error in
emailing so I had to email about that
too it was a real web of emails being
sent
so lastly how do you actually deploy it
um so I needed the server to actually be
that sheet that GT IRL server the shiny
app had to be continuously living
somewhere so the place it is currently
running is on Saturn Cloud um so
Saturday Cloud I'm the chief product
officer of the company and so it's
really nice for this I know it's a
I'm an advertising
so it was actually very nice because I
had two R Studio servers running in
Saturn cloud in the cloud so one was the
one I actually was showing you which is
like how I did the development of the
shiny package in rstudio in a browser
but I also had a r Studio running for
developing the shiny backend and then I
actually had two shiny servers running
on Saturn Cloud one the actual server
the shiny server you saw the the
production one but as well as the
development one that I could test with
and use like fake credit cards and it
would fake send emails um so I ended up
have four systems all running on Saturn
Cloud which is pretty nice and um easy
and most importantly I beta tested this
as a bunch of people to make sure it
worked first
um and that took took a while and helped
me really iron out some usability issues
and that was really nice um as well
so wrapping it all up djirl is a cool
package for ordering cool stuff
um this required me to do a bunch of
things that I assumed might be true and
shiny but I didn't actually know and it
turns out it is which includes receiving
data from an r package listening for
post requests sending and receiving
stripe API calls and um spawning
background processes that didn't slow
down the shiny responsiveness
um I forgot to mention it okay so thank
you
um I forgot to mention in the beginning
that not only can you send GG postcards
but you can also order art prints for
your walls which people have used for
like graduation presents and stuff which
is really cool and people use oh by the
way people use like GG postcards or like
baby announcements and stuff people get
really clever uses for these so uh it's
a lot of fun and they're CG watercolor
which is just a hand painted watercolor
for you if you want it um so you can
install the package with insta uh the GG
Nola's jjr that's not me General sdgirl
you can actually if you want to make one
of your own souvenir commemorative
postcards the codes linked above
um the examples of the code in practice
from the production server are at the
ggrl examples and if you want to see the
slides that's the link but lastly I have
a whole bunch of coupons for 80 off
which means you can get a postcard sent
for 50 cents which is the cheapest
stripe will allow me to do before saying
I can't do that
um so if you come talk to me after I
have so many of these coupons to give
out because I'm really excited for
people to use this so okay thank you
thank you
[Music]